JOSE: A lot of the assumptions,
like the emergence of Creole,
have been in the last 200, 300--
I don't know how long.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: 17th
century, roughly, in Haiti.
JOSE: Is there
any other language
that are not Creoles that we
know developed in the last 500
years?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Well, if
what I'm saying is right--
English itself--
modern English--
has developed not that long ago.
Because middle English was up
to 14th, 15th, 16th century.
English was developing in the
16th century, 17th century--
English the way we know it.
So that variety of English
is relatively much younger
than what Chaucer spoke.
So there is a
notion of that fact
that we call English,
English, can be an illusion.
Because there has
been many English
throughout the centuries.
If you focus on English as
a broader umbrella, then,
of course, it's old.
But if you focus on
English as we speak it now,
it's relatively recent.
So even back might not make
the right cut between, say--
and, actually, sign languages--
did you mention sign languages?
JOSE: Yes.
Because in some sense,
maybe part of the bayous
could be that even
the first Haitian--
at some point, we are
saying that Haitian Creole
is a separate
language from French.
so at some point, there was a--
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
There was a break.
JOSE: Yeah, like
the first instance
that we consider this
a different language
happened fairly recently.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's right.
JOSE: So I was wondering if
could that give more evidence
that this bias could be racial?
Is there any other
language that we
know has emerged
fairly recently and we
see how they treat that
differently compared to Creole?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: You
mentioned Spanglish, right?
One could say that Spanglish
might be even younger, right?
SPEAKER 1: It's a lot
younger, maybe 30, 40 years.
But the thing is, it's
not considered a language.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Well,
actually, it's changing.
I heard recently that,
at some universities
on the west coast--
I was told that by
Professor Spadofa.
Me and Noam Chomsky were
at an interview with Noam.
And she gave us the news
that these universities
were going to start teaching
Spanglish as a language.
SPEAKER 1: You know which one?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: I have to
listen to the interview again.
She did tell us.
But I don't remember which
one, but it's a first.
It's the first in the
history of Spanglish.
Finally, there is
on university that's
agreed to teach
Spanglish as a language.
I think that's
remarkable, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, it's awesome.
But it's not what
Jose is talking about,
just because English
and Spanish were
somewhat prestigious languages
in and of themselves,
and the whole point of Creole
is that it's not prestigious.
JOSE: So I have to think.
Because at the same
time, I know there's
a lot of people in Haiti
who them themselves don't
think Creole is a language.
So maybe I'm being like, well,
Spanglish is not a language.
In some sense, it's because
you know two languages.
And you purposely mix them
because it's convenient.
But I feel like nobody
would say that is a--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: But
actually, languages
have emerged like that.
In Canada, there is a
language called Michif.
Michif is also a mix of French
and some Algonquin language.
There is one in the Indies
called Media Lengua.
In fact, even the name
tells you that it's
a mix of this [INAUDIBLE].
It's called Media Lengua.
What is Media Lengua?
It's a mix between
Spanish and Kichwa.
You see?
And Media Lengua is the
language of the community.
and actually, that case
is very interesting.
Because Media Lengua was
created really mid-way.
Because in the valley, you
had the rich colonizers,
the Spanish people.
And in the top of the mountains,
you had the Kichwa speakers.
And then, in between,
you had these people
who were, in terms
of the social class,
in the midpoint between
the rich Spaniards
and the oppressed
Kichwa speakers.
And they developed
Media Lengua as a way
to show that they
were different,
that they were not exactly
like the Kichwa speakers,
but they were not at the level
yet of the Spanish speakers.
And they used that mixing.
So at first, one could imagine
that people would say, well,
it's another language.
It's just this random mix of
Kichwa words and Spanish words.
But now, Media
Lengua is a language
spoken by a community of people
who, at first, were bilingual.
But now their main
language is Media Lengua.
JOSE: When you combine
languages, that's how it feels.
I really only combine
English and Spanish
when I know the other person
feels most comfortable speaking
that.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: I
think, Ose, you'll
be interested to read about
the history of Media Lengua.
Because I think what
you're describing
in terms of that feeling
that's you know both,
and that you're speaking to
someone who can understand
both, that's what's
been described
by people who've looked at--
So the key linguist here
that you should look at,
his name is Pieter Muysken.
So look up Pieter Muysken.
OK, so it was a beautiful
work describing the origins,
the structure of Media Lengua.
And then what you have to do as
you read that is ask yourself,
is he describing what I feel
now when I speak Spanglish?
I don't know what the answer is.
But that's what comes to my
mind as you describe Spanglish.
I think of Media Langua.
JOSE: Most Mexicans
don't identify too much
with the use of Spanglish.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Well, that's exactly
the way this was created.
Because Media
Langua, the speakers
wanted to create a
new identity for them.
They didn't want to see
themselves as if they
were purely Kichwa speakers,
nor were they Europeans.
So they wanted to create this
compromise between the two
identities.
And they use that mix
of Kichwa and Spanish
to create a new
badge of identity.
Now I don't know whether that's
the same thing for Spanglish.
But from what you describe,
it sounds interestingly
reminiscent to that story.
STUDENT 2: You may have
just touched on it,
but I was going to ask if--
he was talking about
how Mexican's don't
identify with Spanglish,
and they don't speak it.
But is that how these speakers
of French and Algonquin--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah, Michif.
STUDENT 2: --is that
how they felt when
they developed that language?
Because that could be part
of the evolutionary process.
He could be describing that it's
[INAUDIBLE] own way of starting
its own language.
Eventually, the
umbilical cord gets cut.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So I think
the history of Michif
has another twist, which is
that there was a gender issue.
I think there was an issue
of there were Algonquin women
meeting with French speakers.
So there's another
aspect that's not
part of neither Spanglish
nor Media Lengua, which
is the gender part of it and
with who spoke Algonquin,
and who spoke French.
And it was mostly women
who spoke Algonquin.
go ahead.
STUDENT 3: I feel like there's
certain dialects of Spanish
that, in some ways, use
Spanglish legitimately,
like maybe that's
how it would be.
Like, "par-kare," which is not
how you actually say to park
the car.
But that would be considered
Spanglish, wouldn't it?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOSE: For example,
I'm from the border.
I'm from [INAUDIBLE].
And we definitely use a
lot of words that have
English origin, like "troka."
We use "troka" instead
of [INAUDIBLE]..
I didn't know that was the
origin until I was 17, 18.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So
you were using troka
without knowing
that was was with--
JOSE: Yeah, yeah.
Because it doesn't feel like
an English-- you're just--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Troka.
JOSE: Yeah.
And do, OK.
Of course it looks
like a Spanish word.
It just feels like
you're borrowing
words more than
something independent.
I only really combine
English and Spanish
when I'm speaking with somebody
who the bass line is English.
But I have to alternate.
I don't know.
It doesn't feel like--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
So that could be an
interesting research project
because in this case, you
would be your own subject.
So I think that's a fascinating
question that you could ask.